[Music]
[Music]
i'm going to start with 5th buds which
is i think a good warm-up so what do i
have here my environment the way i like
to work and it's very uncommon so i'm
using vim i'm a veeam die hard i never
moved out of vim and i always did
closure in vim
vim is perhaps slightly behind the emacs
ecosystem
but i never felt that what i'm what i'm
not having access to
without the emacs ecosystem is
impacting my way of working very much so
i never found you know a compelling
reason why i shouldn't stay in vim and
my theme is a vim and tmax combination
so
at the top here i have an independent
tmax session below here i have um a
rebel running in another tmax session
and i'm switching happily between the
two evaluating code on the lower
lower
part of the lower side of the screen and
writing at the top so let's get started
let's have a look at that examples i was
mentioning in the book i think the fifth
buzz is in the cond b
so this is the um the live book as you
can see
as you can access it from
the manning
live version of the book you have an
index here on this on the left so let's
go
i think con p might be on the basic
constructs i don't remember 100 so let's
double check there are a few very common
functions
that are detached from a particular
classification
and since they are
very used i put them all in a basic
construct section at the beginning so
third option i have a local copy
which i know is always working let's go
over see where cond b is
so i found the reference here is in
chapter three so as i suspected is in
the basic constructs
and i think it's in the conditional
branching section of the basic
constructs
so in compy
i have this example i think the fifth
bus
and let's copy
the fifth bus
in the
like better looking and colorful syntax
on this side of the screen let's also
grab
the examples that you see here and let's
go
through what it what this thing is doing
so depending on your like on your depth
of knowledge of closure i don't know if
you ever saw conned p
but it's a version
it's if you want it's an enhanced
version of cond so khand would be the
basic constructs
so for example if you have a cond and
some condition for example
something true
then it will take the true branch
something false
it want
of course
and you have also like else option catch
all case
where it's going to return everything
else so of course you are going to cond
on some condition which is not always
true always false so maybe we should put
it in a let
and
reason on something more interesting
like a number for example take it take
the number 2 and see if
even
if n is even
when we print even if
um
if if it's odd
so even an odd are also functions in the
center library even od
else
do no
so if we evaluate this
you should be able to see the evaluation
below in the screen we get an even as
expected so
how
can't b is different from this so say
you have
something slightly different in terms of
conditions so this is an
n equals to let's do something like
you have n
and you have
m
and this m is
i don't know
something which is in the it's a random
integer
between zero and four so rounding is
what is
printing we can see a few examples below
so this is going to return some random
integer between
uh 0 and 4 i think 4 is not going to be
included
we can easily check that
since we have
a good book to check these things out
run int
round and
oh yeah it would be so at the top of
each section
is giving you a contract
and this contract is reporting on what
you can do or not with these functions
so n is the bound for both functions
it must be
or type double for round and type into
four round int
negatives included
and it should tell me here normally the
top what the function does so by default
round produces double we range from zero
and less than one
i didn't specify for rounding
at least it's not at the beginning but i
think it is
excluding the argument we can prove that
can we yeah
example we do
run into one
and we do that
repeatedly
many times
what do we get
um let's see
round
into one
and
this is going to be infinite an infinite
lazy sequence so we take 10 of them so
this is not of course this is not like
a formal proof of anything
but we can see
if we take
1 000 of them
and we do distinct
how many values do i see and i see only
zero so i'm
reasonably
sure that rounding is returning
a random integer between zero
and the the number and passing this
argument excluded so going back to this
let's go to 4
and so i have an n a number n equals 2 a
number m
equals to
something between 0 and 3 0 1 2 3. and
i have a con so the con
for something like this if actually i
don't need the m
so if m equals 0
then 0
if m equals one two
and three so you get the idea where i'm
going with this
so i can actually just return the number
one oops sorry
to
for
else i don't know
so you should definitely
ah actually i didn't need to do that
but there we go a little bit more less
so
in this case i reach the zero branch and
the hd1 branch so what is
what can we improve in this so as you
can see i'm repeating the same equality
every time
i'm going
equals m0 equals m1 equals m2 and so on
with con p i can do that once and for
all so con p
equals m
and then what
any of these numbers
so it allows me to repeat the if um
the con the the test condition is always
repeating the same operation
like
some
function
of the argument
then
it's like if you saw here equals m and
then it is completed by the branch here
so this is the same as before why i'm
doing this because i wanted to show you
how comp works so
going back to our fees buzz
implementation enclosure
what do i see here i see a copy
of a function of the two
arguments
which is taking one first argument n
here
and a second argument is coming from any
of the branches
in the con p
i forgot to mention that yeah the last
branch
is
not necessary to have
it just requires a single
um
you call that
it doesn't require a test expression
essentially
in column b
um but that's a minor detail so let's go
back to the con p so as i said i have a
function of two arguments
and i might realize that now with you
know after after i wrote the book maybe
it would have been easier here to just
make it
not use the
function literal expansion which is like
a way to make things to write less
but make it maybe less readable as well
so i'm going to wrap this in a fn
which is exactly equivalent and specify
the two arguments here which makes it
maybe easier to
um understand
so let's say i have a and b i'm doing
the mod between b and a
and now we're going to understand what
this mod is
and and then going into the branches so
hopefully this is
um still
even more readable
so
what do i have here
um the mod of a number so the mod
operator is basically coming from all
the c
java languages so it's the same thing
it's going to return the rest of
the integer division between the two
numbers
so
mod
of 10 and 5
would return 0 because there's no
rest
but if i do
10
and 3
so the 3 is gonna
can
multiply by three is nine and then
so if i divide ten by three i get
uh
the three can stay in the can i can fit
the ten at least three times and then
there are some decimals
and
if you if we take this as an integer
division then that would be one so the
rest of that integer division would be
one if you want to see the result of the
integer division
then you use div
no
um i forgot
oh something that might i should mention
it's amazing uh how many things
i forget about
the book i wrote given the size and
sometimes i find myself like reading
what i wrote and saying
did i really wrote that and apparently i
did
so i don't remember what it is the
function i'm searching for if i go into
the number
operational numbers section there's a
section quote rem and mod
where i can
remember what was the function i was
searching for which is what so quart of
10 and 3
should be 3. and the reminder of that
operation is one
so going back to the fifth pass example
what do i have
i have mod of b and a so the integer
division between b
and a what is b what is a b is the
second parameter a is the first
the first parameter is always n
and is coming
as a parameter of the function
so if i say
um
fizz bars of
these bars
of
nine
i get fizz
why do i get fizz because
i do
the rest of the integer division between
any of the numbers
here so let's say it's 15 for example
so
mod
b and a in this case let's do it here
mod of 15 and 9
would be 6.
is that 0 no it's not is a rest
so it's not taking any of
the branches of the con p except the
last which is the catch-all
branch so
it will return n would return the number
itself
so if it's bars of nine
uh i did something wrong sorry let me
see
i think so i think that n is what i pass
in
oh say yeah it's that is nine here and
15
would be this one
oh yes what happens is that when i do
that
this function
and i'm arriving
at
3 then i have a zero
zero rest of the integer division so
that's why it's written in fifth what
else then the way i exercise this
this is by doing
a mapping of this bus on a sequence of
numbers
uh note that i don't start from zero to
avoid
the dreaded
division by zero
no there's none
yeah i'm not sure why then
um
this part of zero
is fifth path oh that's why
uh we you know what it depends
because it depends on on the version of
fifth bars you're looking at i mean if
you start from zero you can start from
zero
uh but it's not necessary
so let's say you want to map feeds bats
starting from one then you do the range
from one to twenty maybe it should
explain range as well quickly
but
so range
takes
no argument and is returning an infinite
sequence so
if you do take one from range
it's returning the first number
if you take
10 is returning 10 and
you see where this is going so range
with that argument is going to return an
increasing a monotonically increasing
sequence of integers starting from zero
and then there are several
parameters you can use to change this
monotonically increasing or decreasing
sequence because you can go backward and
forward
so
you can decide to start from a different
number and and a 10
then you do you pass two arguments
then you can also decide the step for
example you could decide to go from
you know 0
to -10
removing one
and so you as you can see we are now
monotonically decreasing i think there
is also another one
let's check it i think there's also
another
argument you can use so range will be in
the basic construct section because it's
one of the most used function because
it's it's the basis for many many things
you can do with the sequences enclosure
so you tend to start with a range
when you need to do some calculations
let's see i just passed -1 but you could
of course change this
and it would generate still
monotonically increasing or decreasing
numbers but with a different step so
instead of one steps of two steps of
three or steps of what you want and now
i'm also looking at the book and i'm
also remembering that you can pass
ratios you can pass doubles as well and
then you can get increment of half
half a number for instance so for
example
you could go from 0 to 10 up into
increments of 0.5 which is quite
interesting because i don't normally use
it and i forgot you could do that
i think there is some
corner case you need to be aware of but
i don't remember it now anyway let's not
go too much of a tangent and let's go
back to the fees buzz implementation so
i think we kind of dissected the entire
thing
we applied that to a range
we are using map maybe i'm not going now
into the details of map but you i'm
mapping a function of one argument to
all of these arguments
and i'm getting
what i think is a quite idiomatic
fifth buzz implementation enclosure i'm
pretty sure you can go as wild as you
want
with the fizzbuzz implementation using
all sort of interesting techniques but i
think this one is um expressive it tells
you what are the rules of this little
game you can see them you can see that
the function that is applied is
zero
mod vna and you can see why
when
this is returning fizzbuzz
fizz or buzz of course
the
order
of the conditionals in the copy matters
so you have to put the fizz bars at the
top for the multiples of 15 and so on
and so forth because if you put it down
below then you're gonna have i think
you're gonna have um
some cases where it's matching the wrong
thing
before matching the right one
yes essentially it can never match 15
because
three is a divisor you'll never be able
to see a fizz buzz if you invert the
order so order is important you should
go first and you should catch that
ahead of everyone
ahead of the other two divisors of 15.
let me post on the chat one of the
challenges i prepared for you without i
repeat the rules
without like copy pasting this directly
into a rebel can you guess what this is
going to print maybe i should also post
it in
here ready for
any explanation we might have
what do we have let's check it so we
have a case statement which is
something similar to a conned statement
but not quite it's got a few important
differences
and it's a fast cond but it's got some
restrictions you cannot do
everything
that you can do with the con statement
so what do we have is
we have
k's of some number
and a few options so this is the way you
would
format the case in a proper way
so case the number four
is
something related to the sum of one and
two
print no
if it's something related to
subtracting three from seven then say
yes
if it's none of the above then print
none any guesses
from people watching the stream so we
got one guess for the yes
which would seem
pretty
natural
and we'll see why
or what is happening when we evaluate
this in a second let's go back to the
other options that we have we had a look
at the fizzbuzz and
the predicate con p uh yeah another
important interesting thing is y is
called cond p the p stands
for predicate at least that would be
like a very good mnemonic
to remember why it's called can't p in
my opinion the predicate is because you
are passing to the compy
sum function and this function is used
to create the condition
uh the conditional branching instead in
cond yeah i i don't have the con anymore
but in cond you would have the
conditional branching based on an
independent function
it could be different for each of the
branches
and so you're not passing the predicate
in
that's why
you